big games this weekend as the nfl moves
toward mid-season there's my top five
peter king's on the right he's got the
chiefs at number one i got him at number
four and he's got the seahawks all the
way down at number five i've got them at
number one but we agree on one thing the
titans at number two and the titans
hosting the steelers the first game
peter that was rescheduled because of
covet 19 issues and actually it's better
now than it would have been a few weeks
ago because the steelers are 5-0 the
titans are 5-0 and it feels like these
are
two of the best teams in the league two
of the best teams in the conference
whoever wins is going to be one of the
only remaining unbeaten teams in all of
football and the question then becomes
are they
in a position to claim that they're the
best team but this is going to be an
old-school 70s style i hope football
game with some some good defense but
surprisingly very potent offense by the
tennessee titans they had 600 yards
against the texans last week and they've
got today's jim brown slash earl
campbell but they also have a guy in
ryan tannehill who after nine years in
the league has finally become a
franchise quarterback
well you know mike you consider that you
know tannehill since he took over the
job one year ago this week
is the highest rated quarterback in the
nfl and he's number one in yards per
attempt which is a respected stat by
offensive people in the league
i think the one thing about this game
that really is interesting every week
you see ben roethlisberger playing a
little bit better and getting a little
bit more comfortable with his
surroundings and now you look at
tannehill you know to me tannehill who
would have thought you know basically
tannehill and ben roethlisberger are on
equal footing entering this mega game
well they are you can say for as long as
you want i still don't believe in
tannehill you're just it's like you
don't believe there's a coronavirus you
know i mean you know the guy has been
absolutely terrific since he came on
board when you're the most efficient
quarterback and you got the the the stat
uh in your corner that says you're the
best guy throwing down field
those are the two things that you want
out of your quarterback one other thing
about the steelers i'm so interested to
see roethlisberger's development with
these young receivers you know even
though they've some of them have been
bouncing in and out of the lineup now
because of injury i want to see him no
it's not just the juju show anymore it's
deonte johnson obviously chase claypool
both of these teams mike you look at
them and you say well they're they both
really want to run the ball and i think
they do
but i think they both can win the game
if you shut down their run game
you know you've got the steelers at
number five in your top five tied with
the seahawks
why are the steelers that low on yours
i want to see more of the pittsburgh
steelers right now and
you know
i guess
i should be
i should i should love the steelers more
after last weekend when we all thought
cleveland was good but that's the thing
in my head
you know i don't really trust cleveland
i definitely don't trust baker mayfield
and so to me
i just i want to see a little bit more
out of the steelers
and again
all of these things really are based on
what have you done for me lately like
right now today
the snapshot in my head
of what the tampa bay buccaneers did to
aaron rodgers i can't unsee that mike
and i don't i i understand they've got
two losses and you know and last week
they lost to the bears and looked feeble
i get it
but in my opinion i base my top five
right now
on what i have seen most recently and
who i would trust today
you know to win a game if these teams
played each other
the pittsburgh steelers have a very good
defense the titans have a very good
offense and they've got derek henry i
mentioned him a minute or two ago i'm
fascinated by the way the steelers are
going to
to play that offense the bill belichick
approach take away what they do best
well the problem with the titans is if
you take away derek henry how do you
take away ryan tannehill and if you take
away ryan tannehill how do you take away
derek henry i think it all starts
with stopping it starts with stopping
the run that's what cam hayward told me
last week when they beat the browns we
got off the bus stopping the run trying
to create frustration and the thing
about derek henry the flaw in his game
if there is one is that he needs two or
three steps to really get going if you
can force him to the outside if you can
keep him from getting ahead of steam and
knock him down close to the line of
scrimmage he never really gets a chance
to kill you now if he gets past that
first level you're done
but you have to get to him early and i
think the steelers have the the brain
power in the coaching staff to figure
out ways to do it and they have the
athleticism and just the raw brute
strength in their front seven to make it
happen especially with taylor lawan out
for the year for the titans with the
torn acl but i think that's going to be
the key we're going to see the steelers
try to stop the run
and try to force ryan tannehill to beat
them baker mayfield wasn't able to do it
last week ryan tannehill's playing a lot
better than baker mayfield right now
we'll see if tannehill's up to this
specific challenge
i thought what was so interesting about
derrick henry in that game last week
everybody is entranced and rightfully so
by the 94-yard run
and the 53-yard pass reception i mean
how absurd was
was derek henry last week but you know
the thing that really interested me
on the key play you know one of the key
plays of the game obviously the five
yard touchdown run out of the wildcat
formation
the thing that intrigued me about that
is
he looked exactly like le'veon bell
on that play you know how le'veon bell
will you know sort of run to the outside
and he'll look and he'll pause for a
minute and say hey come on dude let's go
let's go
but he wanted to see exactly what hole
he was going to attack and when ty
sambrello you know who had taken over at
left tackle
uh you know for for um uh what's his
name who got hurt when he makes the key
seal block yeah uh taylor lamont when he
makes the key seal block
on that side that was the sign right
there for derek henry to burst through
that little gap and to score the
touchdown so
i mean i do think taylor lawn is a very
big loss and now mike it's not just lawn
but now you're playing without lawn on
the left side without conklin who's in
cleveland on the right side and you have
two new tackles
uh from your great run of the great
playoff run of last season so this is
going to be an adjustment for tennessee
yeah look i i've gone back and forth on
this one i ultimately think the steelers
gonna find a way to win it and that's in
part because i'm scarred by what they
did to the browns last week when i
thought the browns were ready
to show the steelers a thing or two
about who's good and who's not good in
the afc north well the steelers are good
and the browns at least when they're
playing their afc north rivals in
baltimore and pittsburgh are not good
not nearly good enough losing 38-6 and
then 38-7
all right seahawks and cardinals the
game has been moved to prime time on nbc
i love me some kyler murray i also love
russell wilson you know we keep looking
for the next tom brady peyton manning
rivalry and typically it's going to be
guys in different divisions who are more
likely to encounter each other in the
playoffs because that's when this
rivalry between quarterbacks really
builds legacies and locks in and has
high drama but we're going to get kyler
murray and russell wilson twice a year
indefinitely we get it on sunday night
here they are talking about each other
from earlier in the week
he's a phenomenal football football
player
he can really throw it he can spin it he
can run around i mean he's quick as a
cat he's just moving around like crazy i
got to know him a little bit through the
draft process and got a lot of respect
for for him and his competitiveness and
we're going to get to play against each
other for many years and it's going to
always be a lot of battle so you know
i'm proud to see just his his work ethic
and success and uh doing it for doing
for the shorter guys uh but he's uh he's
been special for sure
yeah you know he uh
he he really is short he's he's shorter
than me
i was so happy the day i met kyler
murray you know because i'm about
russell wilson's size
uh but but kyler murray whatever they
had him listed at whatever they said he
weighed remember went to the combine the
city away two or five years no unless he
had a bowling ball in his pocket there's
no way this guy weighs 205 but he is
spectacular and i think the fact that
he's so
small in stature makes what he does even
more impressive you know he knows how to
manipulate a defense he knows how to he
just has that uncanny ability to run by
players he knows when to get down for
his own well-being it's going to be fun
to watch what what he is able to do on
sunday night and also what russell
wilson can do i mean it's not like the
cardinals defenses the 85 bears they've
lost chandler jones for the season
buddha baker was very good on monday
against the cowboys but it was the
cowboys with andy dalton with an
offensive line and tatters this seahawks
offense is great two weeks to get ready
for the game cardinals turning around on
a short week actually the few extra
hours i don't know if it helps them or
not it probably doesn't help much but
you know getting it bumped into prime
time gives them a full six days from
when they played their last game as
opposed to the seahawks getting a full
14.
i did this is one that
i believe the seahawks are the better
team right now but you know what they
were the better team last year and
arizona went up to seattle and beat them
there when the seahawks were playing for
a hell of a lot so i'm not going to
write off the cardinals automatically i
think they can give them a game and i
think they're going to give us a lot of
points on both sides of the ball peter
yeah you know what seattle
one of the reasons why i really i don't
know about seattle yet
i know we're talking about them going
maybe getting antonio brown
man i'll tell you what if i were them
i'd want to activate snacks harrison
soon and i'd want to get an outside
presence in the pass rush game um you
know with the trading deadline if i
could
but you know two things about this game
i always think back to the first time i
met kyler murray it was a cardinals camp
in 2019
i watch a practice they practice inside
their stadium
and i wait for him after practice
and i introduce myself shake his hand
and he goes
yeah i know you i've seen you on the
internet
and i thought
now that is an interesting way to have
met somebody and to know somebody you
know i've seen you on the internet okay
that's the first thing the second thing
is mike
watching him on monday night
i said i i you know i'm serious i was
going to bed at halftime i could barely
make it through halftime but i watched
him and i just said man i i want to i
want to stay up and watch more kyla
murray
he is a barrel of fun
to watch play the sport of football
and and i just and the more i watched
him that night the more i said look he's
not an accurate downfield thrower right
now okay
but
he creates so many problems for a
defense
with those legs he's just
he's just i just think he's a
fascinating fascinating player i i'll
sign up to watch him every week
and you know peter it reminded me of the
rams ravens monday night game last year
when the ravens were blowing out the
rams but you kept watching to see what
lamar jackson was going to do next i
want to watch and see what kyle murray
is going to do next i don't care what
the score is one thing that chris
mentioned earlier in the week now this
is based on his experience as a
quarterback not as an orthopedic surgeon
because he ain't one but he says keep an
eye on that arm of kyler murray he just
detected in his body language something
that suggested maybe he's got some sort
of tendinitis or something going on and
he noticed just little things like when
kyle murray walked off the field
he was unbuckling his chin strap with
his left hand even on his right side
where the easy thing to do is pull your
right arm up and pop it there that's the
logical thing to do when you're when
you're using your off arm to do
something like that
it suggests that maybe there's some
discomfort in that arm that you use to
throw the football so it's just
something to watch you know he still was
very effective but uh just it's one of
those maybe chronic things that will
linger they could maybe get worse that
maybe at some point we see him leave the
game on sunday night but but keep that
in the back of your mind there could be
something there he's not on the injury
he's not on the injury report but it's
something chris noticed and i give that
plenty of credence are you buying the
cardinals though at this point one to
ten where would you put them
with 10 being really good five and a
half
five and a half i mean i think they're i
think they're nine and 17.
it might be good enough to get the
seventh seed
but i mean first of all
it's easy to say in a vacuum yeah
they're nine and 17.
i mean that is one of the best divisions
we've seen in a while that's the
anti-nfc east
so
you know every game you play in that
division home or away everyone you can
lose now obviously they had the huge win
at san francisco
you know early but uh but my my point is
that
you have to look at every game you play
in that division
as i don't want to say a mega game but
as the kind of game that you could lose
and it wouldn't be a shock so
i think nine and seven would be a great
accomplishment this year for the arizona
cardinals
yeah you know all those years that they
were stuck in the nfc east when the
giants in washington and dallas and
philly were good and they were just the
cardinals wouldn't they love to go back
there right now
i mean this idea of going five six and
five they'd love it put us back in the
in the division where we never fit
geographically even when we were in st
louis we shouldn't have been in there we
definitely shouldn't have been in there
once we moved to phoenix but right now
they'd be the best team by far
in the nfc east i feel bad for the
cardinals and i really i really want
them to have a chance to become as good
as they can be and i want to see kyler
murray play all the time i'm i'm happy
that we get seahawks cardinals in prime
time yeah it would have been great yeah
i am too i think that's really good
it'll be it'll be great it'll be great
to watch it'll be great to watch
although you're right i really did want
to see brady v gruden i mean that would
have been fun if only because you know
what i really wanted to see mike i
wanted to see fred goodelli and drew
esikoff and what they were going to come
up with
for the tuck rule game
you know i i
what sort of fun little
visages uh you know you were you were
going to see
sunday leading into that game because
obviously
that is a game that will live in infamy
for every raiders fan that's worse than
any that's that you know what it's not
worse than the immaculate reception but
it's very very close
and i think every raider fan of this era
of this generation that's the one loss
in sports they'll never get over
now
it is possible we are going to see that
game let's not just gloss over the
reality that this game may be played on
tuesday night or part of another monday
night double header which would be the
fourth of the year selfishly i want it
tuesday i i tell you
hey peter they've discovered plutonium
by accident with this and as
i'm telling you
as or by necessity as the case may be
but as
as legalized
sports wagering continues to spread the
nfl is going to understand the value
especially when we get to the point
where they solve the latency issue and
people can pick up their phone and they
can make real-time bets during games the
nfl is going to realize there's more
money to be made by everyone if they
break out games from that one o'clock
and four o'clock cluster on sundays and
find other windows this tuesday night
window or this other alternative monday
night game on a regular basis i'm
telling you they're going to realize
this is what they need to do and i kind
of we're getting used to it where's our
extra early week prime time game we want
one even though it's the result of some
sort of coven 19 complication we're not
complaining about why we got it we just
want it i'd love to have that buccaneers
raiders game now moved to monday night
or tuesday night
now mike
i had somebody you know who knows a
little bit about the television business
and who knows about the nfl television
business
tell me
watch out
for one of the streaming services now
that everybody has to remember
in 2021 and basically 2022
when these contracts basically
are are in play and i think it gets done
before
2022
but someone told me
do not
think that it's out of the realm of
possibility in part because of the 17th
game that the nfl will start playing
next year
so basically you've got
16 more games to sell
you know in the next television contract
and they told me do not be surprised
if a streaming service
such as amazon
if a streaming service takes
not just one or two games or not just
being
you know an extra
feed uh you know on the thursday night
games
okay
don't be surprised to see them actually
take a package of games
and and i just i mike
i think this is wrong and i think the
players association would have to have
something
huge in return
but how about a streaming game
every tuesday night
at 8 15 p.m
on one of these amazon googles facebook
whatever it is
you know say 10 weeks a year
and then you do some huge
favor you do some huge trade
with the nfl pa
uh you know to play games on tuesday
night and look i'm not saying that it
will happen or won't i have no idea but
all i know is that watching these this
extra game on monday in the game on
tuesday has really started to make me
think
why not tuesday
yeah i agree with you completely and we
may get buccaneers raiders on tuesday
we're getting 49ers patriots 4 25
eastern on sunday first time the 49ers
go back to new england since 2012 when
they were bedeviled on a sunday night by
colin kaepernick now it's jimmy
garoppolo second round pick in 2014
traded three years ago going back to new
england here's a little jimmy g on the
patriots and a little bill belichick on
jimmy g
i mean my time in new england was
awesome i enjoyed every bit of it
and i you know got me to where i'm at
today
i'm glad that it's worked out um for him
in san francisco i hope it doesn't work
out on sunday but
otherwise
happy that he had the opportunity to
play for a you know great coach and a
great organization
and playing a great team i think he
deserves that
well he got that opportunity and he
carried the 49ers to the super bowl last
year even though he was bob griese for
much of the postseason before the super
bowl game handing the ball off
repeatedly all he needed was the glasses
that greasy used to wear during games
but this is jimmy g's chance to come
back and this is belichick's chance to
show what he learned
from jimmy g in practice that's the one
thing i can't get away from there's no
one who's going to have filed away any
and all of the things that he noticed
from jimmy garoppolo that could be
exploited in the future especially once
he knew at some point in 2017 that he's
probably going to be trading this guy
let's beef up our dossier of jimmy g
information that we're going to have to
use at some point of course when you
trade them out of the conference that
some point is several years down the
road but now that time has come and bill
belichick has to retreat to his notes
and see what he's got on jimmy g and
that's one of the reasons why i think
the 49ers may have a hard time on sunday
you know how fast the nfl world spins
because who would have thought that in
2012
when colin kaepernick went up to
foxborough on that
ugly
cold rainy night
you know uh who would have thought that
colin kaepernick would have such a short
shelf life and i can't help but think
right now mike that
i'm not saying jimmy g is playing for
his job necessarily in the next few
weeks
but
if he plays this year the way he played
in january i'm not saying he will
but he is yet to really prove himself
totally you think he's going to be the
quarterback for the next 10 years in san
francisco but you know you really don't
know
and you know how amazing would it be if
you
if you look at the 49ers in 2012 ah they
have their franchise guy in kaepernick
and then now 2020 how they got their
franchise guy in garoppolo
who's going to be their quarterback in
2024 when the patriots play in santa
clara
you know against 90 year old bill
belichick
well and and hey i still think there's a
way the dominoes fall that jimmy
garoppolo ends up back in new england i
i you know this is all on jimmy g as to
whether or not he's going to secure his
future with the 49ers one week it looks
like he will one week it looks like he
won't they considered tom brady and told
him they were considering tom brady
which is kind of a nice way of saying
you better step it up or we're going to
explore our options every year until we
decide to go in a different direction so
this one has just the potential to show
us where jimmy g is
what bill belichick has retained by way
of dealing with jimmy g and and the one
reality it doesn't matter maybe he does
morph into bob griese again this weekend
because bill belichick is concerned
about that 49ers running attack and
something sims has been saying all week
you know you don't have the defensive
lineman in new england currently that
can that can thwart it so maybe it will
just be run the ball run the ball run
the ball run the ball from every
different position running back full
back tight end receiver and the the the
patriots just can't stop it peter
yeah i think i think this game could
really go either way and i mean on the
scoreboard and philosophically
because right now look i think bill
belichick said it absolutely right after
the game wasn't making an excuse he was
just simply saying we need to practice
period look at cam newton okay so cam
newton basically has the month of august
to practice with his new team and to win
the job he doesn't practice with him at
all in the offseason but he's got the
month of august to practice with him and
then he's there basically for september
and then bang coven
okay so i still don't know exactly how
often in like a 14-day span
that cam newton actually practiced or
was able to be a fully functioning uh
physical human being
you know so so you still don't really
know what cam newton is with this
offense and if you saw him last weekend
mike and you saw them sort of rely on
the crutch of the edelman option pass
you know you say i god this is this is
terrible because the patriots weaponry
is awful we know that it's not deep in
any way shape or form
and so they need cam newton to be that
multiple weapon every single week or you
don't know if he's going to run it 13
times or pass it 36 times that it's
incumbent on the patriots to build that
the only way you do that is with
practice and that's why i think
that this week had to have been a very
comforting week for the patriots to be
able to practice
another issue too mike reese of espn.com
pointed this out the receivers are not
getting separation that's part of the
problem as well for the new england
patriots so practice yes they need to be
able to get on the field they need to be
able to get ready they need to be able
to get their guys better especially when
it's a work in progress type of a team
that is going to be better in november
and december you know i keep the
patriots relatively high despite their
record in my power rankings because i
think they will get better the more
they're together the more they get
comfortable and the more that they're
able to practice and play and that
you look at the great teams right now in
the afc peter ravens steelers titans
chiefs
the last team any of them will want to
see
the first round that they play in the
postseason is the new england patriots
because they're going to be dangerous in
that single elimination setting when we
get to january
they're not as dangerous now but they're
going to be better and they're going to
be a tougher team to beat when it's time
to put your entire season on the line
based on the outcome of one game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports